we talked last hour about the chicago
quarterback with the base value of 10
million this year and what it means for
him as a starter or not with the bears
in washington it's another base contract
although not really 10 it's nine but
with per game roster bonuses it gets to
ten it's ryan fitzpatrick introduced as
the new quarterback in washington
presumably the starter pending other
moves here's fitzpatrick with his
introduction to the media as the member
of his ninth nfl team
it's interesting that
in year 17 i mean this was the
most sought after i had been in my whole
career with all this free agency stuff
you know i think part of it was just the
way it went the last two years the
adversity that
we fought through as a team and the the
thing that
you know we were able to do to turn it
around in miami and
um
i'm just
i'm excited i'm excited to be here uh
you know i i just think
moving around so much uh just there's
different things that you see from
organizations that you like and you
don't like and you try to carry them
with you
amazing career for ryan fitzpatrick and
uh yeah he got plenty of attention he
had plenty of interest but at the end of
the day
it's not a gigantic quarterback contract
he's still 35 million south of the top
of the market but for a guy who's been
around a guy who's gotten paid plenty of
money a guy who at one point was the
bill's
maybe close to almost franchise
quarterback before it fell apart there
he gets his shot in washington with the
team that won the division
a team that is systematically getting
better some of the free agency moves
like the curtis samuel edition at
receiver william jackson at corner sims
the big william jackson fan and you've
got that great pass rush already in
place with chase young this is just a
team that that is gradually putting in
place
better and better and better players in
a division that is the worst in football
and uh i like this my only concern with
fitzpatrick you never know when fits
magic becomes fits tragic and you better
be ready when it does
but uh
it looks like he's gonna be the starter
in washington unless some guy that they
love falls to them at number 19 in round
one you do love saying that's tragic i
think any time i love it been on this
show and he's always it's tragic oh look
at this yeah he's been in the league for
so long and gone to so many different
teams hey mike did you know that he went
to harvard too he's an ivy league guy i
wear that i've never heard that's really
cool
can you imagine 17 years in the nfl and
i was never aware that he went to
harvard next you're going to tell me
jerome bettis is from detroit
he is oh my gosh no that's why it was so
cool when they played the super bowl
there
well i'm surprised that you didn't know
that as well
that you have but yeah i forgot i've
i've forgotten these things it's part of
me you know yeah i guess so uh but yeah
you know i i think ryan fitzpatrick is a
good fit for what they're doing i mean
even though ryan fitzpatrick has not
taken a team to the playoffs which is
kind of amazing but also not when you
see that he's gone through so many
different teams um in 17 years i think
that he has the chance to do it because
this is a good team around him and it
probably could be one of the best teams
he's ever played on around him i think
miami also last year was one of those
squads so
when you look at it that way
he's a guy that will make some mistakes
but he's also not afraid to let it go
and that's something that i think that
washington needs like he's certainly
better than what they had last year and
they still went to the playoffs now they
were seven and nine last year and made
it to the playoffs so i don't
necessarily know what that means but you
know maybe they can go uh nine and eight
this year or whatever it's gonna be or
uh ten
and nine oh gosh i just messed up the
numbers ten and seven yeah ten and seven
two ten and seven ten five and two
yeah something like that right where
they make it to the playoffs and maybe
they're better it because they have a
better qb so i think tyrion fitzpatrick
has at least that potential
last night on pftpm we did a little
segment where we came up with questions
that we would would ask of quarterbacks
because it was a takeoff on the jared
goff social media ask him any questions
which i'm sure was just a disaster for
whichever intern had to pick through
those questions but i'd i'd love to know
from ryan fitzpatrick how seriously
miami tried to keep him around because
that relief pitcher dynamic was real and
there was value in him staying with
miami and when we had tuatanga viloa on
the show super bowl week i asked him
point blank do you want fitzpatrick to
come back and he evaded the question uh
which doesn't surprise me cause yeah you
don't want that guy hovering over your
shoulder you don't want you want to be
the one who's making the throw late in
the game with the raiders defensive
player twisting your helmet sideways and
everyone's talking about you
that next day and buzzing about what you
did for the rest of that night that was
one of the most exciting games of the
year so he didn't want him there i just
wonder whether the dolphins really
wanted him there because now well they
have jacoby brissette but i'd have more
faith in fitzpatrick
being able to conjure up the fitz magic
on demand when replacing tuatanga viloa
as that relief pitcher that mariano
rivera down in miami late in the game
yeah i would too and i think look when
two was starting obviously there were
some things that they were doing well
they won more games certainly i mean
they had more opportunities to do so but
at the same time i mean one of those
wins that is credited to toga by loa
really should go to ryan fitzpatrick
because it's that raiders game where he
came in and he saved the day and so if
you're still in a situation in 2021 with
tua where you basically can't always
trust that he's going to be able to read
defenses effectively then that's a
problem i don't necessarily know how
well jacoby brissette is going to be
able to play that relief pitcher role if
it's absolutely necessary but i mean
it's something that could certainly
happen if tua tagovailoa doesn't take
the steps necessary to become better or
you know if the miami dolphins say i'm
gonna choose somebody else at number
three overall because they could also
have their selection of quarterbacks
there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports